people don't lean into their dreams
because they're afraid you're afraid of
it not working you're afraid of people
judging you you're afraid of you being a
failure but if you never lean into your
dream you'll always know that you are
capable of more and regret the fact that
you never had the courage to really take
your shot I think we constantly go
through this I I recently went through
this late last year where I got invited
to speak at Brendan burchard's event and
a couple thousand people in the room and
up until that point I hadn't done a big
speaking event for a while I've done a
lot of small events small small meetups
and in my head I was telling myself I
just want to do a q a q a is the easiest
for me it's the most fun for me it's the
easiest for me all I have to do is show
up and so I I told them hey what if we
just did a q a and one of the hosts can
interview me we'll do q a and it will
open up to the audience because that's
the most fun knowing that it's helping
somebody else in the audience and they
said we don't really want to do that
format like okay no problem no problem
I'm in I'll speak and at the two events
prior I did q a i I brought it up to the
organizer they liked the idea and then
we went to q a and I shined in Q a and
again I love it I'm great at it but it
also is a easy crutch for me because I
don't need to prepare for anything if I
didn't go I would have missed out on
such an amazing opportunity right from
that one event where I spoke on Brendan
stage a couple thousand people he then
invited me back to come and speak again
in Puerto Rico to his big Mastermind
group to help him and his business and
me and mine as well if I sabotage myself
and said no I only want to do q a I
wouldn't have gotten that opportunity
and so even though I was super afraid
and so it's leaning into the dream the
reality for me was I was just afraid I
still am afraid need motivation watch a
top 10 would believe Nation hey this is
Nina Carmichael and we made these videos
because you know you're the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan Carmichael
and his top 10 rules for success
[Music]
rule number two keep going the only
thing you're missing is momentum you've
got all the tools available to you it
has never been easier to build your
dreams to reach an audience to create
the company you want never easier all
you're missing is momentum sustained
daily ever-present momentum and today
I'm going to show you how to get it one
of the only reasons why I've had success
on YouTube is that just kept going when
I first started on the platform 11 years
ago it's crazy that it's been that long
you can kind of see some of the awards
behind me here behind the the books but
I built to serve it's an amazing book
11 years ago when I first started my
first video was on Walt Disney I had my
friend Mark draker huge friend of the
channel come in and helped film it for
me and and help edit for me and in the
first year of that video being up there
were only three comments on it one was
my mom one was my oldest sister and one
was some other random guy who commented
on my video right in a year of my first
video going up only one person that I
didn't know commented on the video
YouTube at the time was not a long form
platform YouTube 11 years ago was
something that people were posting
really silly meme videos and just jokes
and pranks but really short form videos
nobody was making long videos 10 minute
videos 12 minutes it didn't exist and it
took me five years to get to 7 000
subscribers I knew because that's when I
passed 1 million views after five years
I crossed a million views and I got 7
000 subscribers and then in the past six
years it's gone from 7 000 subscribers
to two point whatever million and a
million views to 300 whatever million
views I just kept at it now my journey
doesn't have to be your journey it
doesn't have to take you that long if
you're trying to build up a YouTube
channel it may but it doesn't have to
one I'm super introverted and nervous
and and filming and even now this stuff
makes me nervous get in front of the
camera because I want every video to be
the best that I've ever done YouTube at
the time was not an educational platform
that has changed so there's lots that
was against me but the only reason why
I've passed so many other creators is
just because I kept going because I had
the thing that most people Miss which is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum it was actually sad for me
for when I passed some of the speakers
that I looked up to and I aspired to be
like from a speaker point of view
because I figured these guys are so much
more talented to me these guys have so
many more abilities than me they're more
naturally gifted and they put in so much
work to be great speakers and it made me
sad when I passed them on YouTube
because I felt man these guys they
should be out there more I feel like
their message needs to be heard the only
difference was I was just putting in
more work on YouTube they're off doing
their other things well but from a
YouTube perspective I was just building
more momentum I just had more sustained
energy to it and you see this so often
with entrepreneurs not just YouTube
entrepreneurs so often you got a great
idea and you start and there's so much
energy and momentum and then and then
you don't get immediate results and so
you stop and then you get motivated
again and you keep going and then and
then you quit again and you and you give
up it's that sustained Evergreen ongoing
daily momentum that you're missing even
if it's just an hour a day maybe you
have a job you need to survive awesome I
understand yes pay the bills you don't
have to burn all the boats and burn all
the bridges as the only way that this
business is going to take off
sustained momentum every single day has
to be part of what you're doing and so
I've had success on YouTube because I've
made 6 000 videos again I'm not super
talented uh took me a long time to get
here I'm a result of just every day
getting up and doing the work and
chances are whoever your heroes are
whether it's Tony Robbins or Steve Jobs
or Oprah Winfrey or whoever it is look
at their story it was every day getting
up doing the work even if they weren't
getting results knowing that the only
thing missing the only thing you are
missing is that sustained momentum
because you're a genius you have a great
idea that idea needs to be birthed into
the world you're just not doing enough
daily action to make it actually happen
rule number three do do difficult things
self-love comes from doing difficult
things self-love self-confidence
self-respect all of it comes from doing
difficult things and praising yourself
for doing them I think it's one of the
most important things that people don't
do enough
but I think in order to actually make
the praise stick you have to prove to
yourself that you're worthy of it by
doing difficult things you can say I'm a
badass entrepreneur you can say I'm
amazed and I love myself but what your
brains ain't gonna say well no you don't
no you don't
show me what have you done you you're
waking up and then the same thing you
did yesterday at least this is the
conversation in my head so by doing
difficult things by doing the thing even
if you don't get the result
it doesn't matter about the result
you're tying your self-worth your
self-confidence to the effort to trying
the difficult thing to taking action on
a difficult thing that you were scared
to do if you woke up every day and did
something that made you scared that was
difficult that made your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom like that
you did that every day and then you
praised yourself afterwards for the
effort
I promise you you're gonna love yourself
I promise you're gonna go off and do
amazing things you're gonna take that
idea that you've got and go off and
actually execute it and actually
implement it one of the biggest reasons
why you're not is because you don't
believe in yourself that's why I think
lack of belief is the single biggest
problem in the world I'm trying to solve
the world's biggest problem people don't
believe in themselves enough the woman
who solves cancer is a manager at some
restaurant and she hates her life
because she never believed in herself
enough to actually go down the path that
you should have gone down because she
listened to her parents and friends and
family and Society to go do the safe
thing
just gotta save boring life that she
hates because she doesn't love herself
and she doesn't believe in herself
enough and so you have to do the things
that make you scared that are difficult
that are difficult it's not about being
Fearless it's about feeling the fear and
still going off and doing it and then
saying I'm amazing because I try because
if you woke up every day and did
something where you felt amazing that
you tried
you're gonna actually go off and
accomplish amazing things and you're
gonna feel amazing about yourself rule
number four bring more value the number
one rule if you want to make more money
is you have to bring more value want to
make money quickly provide value quickly
want to make tons of money provide tons
of value if you are not making money yet
it's because people don't see the value
that you bring and we're gonna change
that in this video so one of the first
people that I had any kind of
arrangement with on the top 10 series
that I have on my channel was Tony
Robbins I made a video on Tony Robbins I
don't know how many years ago now the
first top 10 that I did on him and his
team put it on his YouTube channel so it
may still be there if you go to his
YouTube channel and then look at the
playlist you'll see that one of those
videos is the video that I made on him
so many years back and I started trying
to bring as much value to his team as
possible now Tony is a really busy guy
uh I loved him from all the books that
he's written and the CD programs that I
listen to you I hadn't been to an event
yet at that point and I was just trying
to bring value to Tony's team I didn't
know him personally yet and it
frustrated me that he wasn't more on
YouTube and I thought hey this guy needs
to be on more on YouTube I want more
content for my channel and I just think
I think the world needs more amazing
speakers and thought leaders out there
creating content on YouTube so people
can learn and so I kept in touch with
his team and I said hey I'd love to help
promote Tony I'd love to help you with
your YouTube channel I'd love to have
Tony on my channel and and I just kept
trying to find ways to bring value to
his team consistently following up and
finally here's what happened finally
they agreed hey yeah let's have Tony
come and do an interview on your team
and finally they said hey let's have
Tony come and do an interview on your
Channel
and I was so excited I was super nervous
because I have Tony Robbins on my
channel it's gonna be a big deal and
then like the day of or the day before
you had to cancel
for for something happened something
came up on the schedule no problem he
had to cancel and all of the nerves and
energy is like oh no now that's a
disappointment that
is finally gonna happen and then it's
not gonna happen then you say we'll try
to we'll try to book it in as soon as
possible to get to get it happening
because Tony wants to be on your channel
great
it took two years before we actually got
Tony on the channel afterwards two years
and and that's not that's not the throw
shade of Tony I love him he's busy is
doing his own thing I wasn't bringing
enough value to to make it sooner uh but
what I did was I kept in touch I kept
following up not just saying hey is Tony
ready yet hey is Tony ready hey is Tony
writing it no I'm bringing value I'm
helping them with their YouTube channel
I'm giving them suggestions I'm helping
promote their events I was doing stuff
to try to still be in the circle to stay
top of mind so that when the next
opportunity came up which happened to be
when he launched his next book to say I
want to be top of mind and Tony agreed
to do five different remote interviews
uh for the for his new book and that was
one of the five and and his team said
you've been so viable to us you've been
helping us so much we appreciate it uh
we want you to be one of the five that
Tony does at an interview with like it's
happening is that Huff Pinch Me for real
this time I hope it's happening and then
the day out he showed up and and I was
super stressed out and nervous about
asking the right questions and trying to
bring value again I don't want to
disappoint people and uh and it went he
showed up it went great we had an
awesome interview and at the end he then
said hey Evan uh I'd like to invite you
as my guest to my next uh seminar which
is coming up in New Jersey Unleash the
Power then
and he invited me to like front row
seats special lounge access and all all
the perks uh meet him backstage because
he wanted to chat and take a picture
which then led to more events and other
opportunities and then speaking and then
you know connecting with Brendan
burchard's team and like lots of stuff
happened
through the Tony Robbins world and
connection
because I stayed and I followed up
because I kept trying to bring value and
even after the first time when they got
the cancellation on me I still followed
up for two more years and kept providing
value for two more years right it's dog
on the bone I want this to work I'm
gonna find another way through until
finally it did and then things took off
and so the same thing for you and your
business if you want to have success
it's about thinking about ways you can
provide more value it's not that you
can't provide value it's not that you're
not talented that you're not a genius
you are people just don't recognize the
value that you can bring yet and you
haven't figured out how to bring that to
Market in a way that you're going to get
paid to do it also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five follow through your
goals we give up too easily on our goals
because we've proven to ourselves that
we can't follow through on our goals
every time you set a goal and you don't
follow through you're creating the
pattern in your head the mindset the
identity that I'm the kind of person who
doesn't follow through
so what happens the next time you set a
goal well your your brain will kick in
to say you're not going to do that how
many times have you set a goal for
yourself it might be some big giant goal
right like I'm gonna crush this year and
I'm gonna be here by the end of the year
awesome might be some big goal but
chances are even the little ones even
the little goals like I'm gonna work out
today or I'm gonna eat well today or I'm
gonna make that call today how many
times have you set even a little goal
for yourself and then not follow through
you didn't do it
you're not allowed to do that anymore
you have to be very intentional about
the goals you set for yourself and then
once you set them you have to follow
through because what's happening is you
don't believe you anymore
the next time you come up with another
goal you say I'm going to create this
thing
I'm going to get this thing done you
might believe it in the half second that
you decided you're gonna do it
I know what happens your brain's gonna
take over and say you're not gonna do
that thing are you crazy
what makes you think you're gonna do
that you didn't do these other 100
things you said you were gonna do either
your goals don't count until they're
hard
and it starts with as soon as you set a
goal you follow through and expect it to
be difficult if it's easy it's a gift
expect it to be difficult and show
yourself that you do difficult things
rule number six figure out your who if
you want to stop living the life that
other people want for you you have to
understand your most important core
value I call it your who it's from my
book build to serve and when you figure
it out it gives you the freedom to start
living the life that you actually want
to live decisions become easier life
becomes easier and your confidence
starts to Skyrocket and I'm gonna tell
you how to do it in this video so my who
is believe my one word is believe it
comes from my parents they're here on my
wall behind me I'm eight or nine years
old in this picture and my parents are
above me and they would always tell me
I'm Evan kastrally Carmichael that I can
do anything that I believe that I can my
favorite movie is Seabiscuit which is
about this horse that is too small and a
jacket that's too big and an owner that
has no money and somehow they all come
together and in the middle of the
depression to to create this amazing
story I love cheering for the undertalk
I love the idea that if you just believe
in yourself more you're going to be able
to create amazing things and so believe
is my one word most important core value
it's my who so once you figure that out
it gives you Clarity over everything
else in in my life so look at the videos
that I make it's always positive all my
videos are always positive I always try
to inject believe into everything that I
do into this video right now right here
that you're watching hey what's up
YouTube welcome thank you for watching I
always try to make it about belief now I
may not achieve it I mean I've done a
good job you may not be feeling believe
after watching this but it's always my
intention going in it's why I don't have
negative videos if I did the top 10
stupidest things that Jordan Peterson
had said or the top 10 fights between
Kanye and whoever that would actually
blow up more that would that would blow
up more people would rather consume
negativity than positivity I just don't
want to make that video It Doesn't fill
me out but it's not my purpose it's not
why I'm here creating the content that
I'm creating and so when you figure out
what your one word is when you figure
out what your who is your most important
core value it allows you to stay on the
path to create the life that you want so
if you come to me with an opportunity
that is not about believe it's an easy
no where otherwise it's hmm should I do
it I don't know the money might be good
but it feels a little gross right it's
an easier decision path and if you're
bringing people in to join your team you
now know what you're looking for I need
people who can yes Video Edit hey
Christina but I also need people who
believe and believe right who want to
help other people out so having that
Clarity gives you the rock to stand on
because you're going to be pulled in a
million different directions right your
parents want you to do something your
friends want you to do something the
news wants you to do something the
people around you are all telling you do
this and do this and do this and it's
like you don't know what to do and you
see somebody with confidence somebody
who's off chasing their dream and it's
easier just to say well I'm gonna go and
follow that person where you could be an
amazing leader yourself the only thing
missing is you don't know what you stand
for when you figure out your who you've
got the rock to stand on when everybody
else is on quicksand and drowning you're
on your rock and you know what you need
to do rule number seven
thing in life is to model success you
want business success you want
relationship success you want financial
success whatever it is you want to learn
somebody's done it and the fastest way
to learn is to go find somebody
understand what it took for them to
become a success and then apply it to
your business to your life to your
situation
the problem is we feel like we have to
do everything ourselves that you don't
know what to do so I'm going to figure
this out right I'm creative I'm a genius
I can I can figure it out and yes you
can but chances are it's going to take
you a lot longer
instead of trying to come up with
everything yourself it's better to build
upon what other people have already done
they could take you eighty percent of
the way it's not going to be a hundred
percent right if you're trying to get
big on YouTube great you can copy what
I'm doing but it's not going to take you
100 of the way it'll take you eighty
percent of the way because if all you do
is copy me you're going to be in every
Junior
which will take you a good chunk but at
best you're going to be a junior Evan
you're never going to be what you could
be
and so you need to take what I'm doing
learn from it but then tweak that last
20 to make it your own how do you take
what other people have done and then
tweak that last 20 to make it your own
but modeling success takes you eighty
percent of the way
this is the biggest mistake I made when
I was starting up as an entrepreneur
right I told the story a bunch but I was
I was 19 I was struggling I was making
300 bucks a month I'm too embarrassed to
tell my friends that I'm struggling I'm
not having success I feel like a loser I
feel like I'm you know I'm not making
any money not just feel like it I wasn't
making any money and and I tried to
think my way out of everything I was
working my face off right like every
waking hour almost I was I was working
it wasn't for lack of effort I was just
doing the wrong thing so they didn't
know what to do because I was just
trying a whole bunch of stuff and then
that worst day of my life when I told my
partner that I quit
you know I just woke up the next day and
said I can't quit because I'm going to
regret this I know I'm going to regret
this advice if I stop now I'm going to
regret it I have to find a way to keep
going but the way that I've kept the way
that I keep going has to change because
what's going on now this this can't keep
going on if you're frustrated with the
lack of momentum towards accomplishing
your goals in life like if you're in the
same spot that you were a year ago or
relatively close the problem likely uh
could be lack of effort but is also like
you're just doing the wrong things
you're just focused on the wrong model
and so go find somebody who's done what
you want to do for me I studied Bill
Gates I was out of
pure desperation I was not a genius when
I was 19 and trying to figure out my way
I was at Rock Bottom I just said
somebody has built a software company
before this can't be so hard right and I
looked at Bill Gates and how he started
right how did he start zero to one
that's what you need to study because if
you look at what people are doing now
one it
it's going to be hard to compare
yourself to if you compare yourself to
what I'm doing now I have 20 something
people on my team you can't like don't
expect yourself to keep up with what I'm
doing right now don't expect to keep up
with 11 years of experience right you're
not going to be as good when you first
get started that's okay but how did I
start how do they keep going whoever
you're looking at look at their
Foundation Story how they started and
chances are you already have more than
what they started with rule number eight
take out negativity from your head you
have allowed too many negative voices
into your head and they're preventing
you from achieving your dreams maybe
it's your friends your parents your
community the people around you or worst
of all maybe it's yourself you cannot do
great things with those negative voices
inside your head you need to eject them
immediately in this video will show you
how so I have a term for those negative
voices I call it the little man the
little man is the either the voice
inside your head or the people around
you telling you all the reasons why
you're not gonna win all the reasons why
this project this idea this dream of
yours is not gonna happen it's never
gonna happen not a million years is that
gonna happen right we all have people in
our life who tell us that or also us
telling ourselves and the idea for
little man came from the very first
video that popped on my channel there
was a video called I believe that I
loved and it was when I just discovered
my who my one word which is believe I
just found out what it was and I wanted
to make kind of a tribute video to that
concept on my YouTube channel and I made
this video that was six and a half
minutes long or so and I showed it to
somebody who was in the entertainment
industry and I asked him to take a look
at it and he he just destroyed it he
said
this video is way too long six and a
half minutes uh nobody's gonna watch it
uh I didn't understand how the internet
worked all all sorts of comments about
how bad this video was and to be honest
a younger version of Evan might have
listened to him and tried to cut it down
and and make it fit within the box that
he wanted to be inside and
for whatever reason I just had a little
more strength and confidence and said
you know what maybe maybe he doesn't
like it but I'm just gonna I'm gonna do
it anyway I'm gonna post it anyway I
like it it inspired me and if it
inspired me maybe it's gonna Inspire
other people too so he posted it and at
the time my best video had a hundred
thousand views it took uh took a year to
get that video to 100 000 views this
video went live and in a month at a
hundred thousand views in the first
month at a hundred thousand views and
now sits around I think 2 million views
on the channel and so quickly became my
best video now it's not my best video
but at the time it was the first video
to you know pop after a month like this
is crazy it's taking off
and I thought man what if I listened to
the little man
what if I listen to him I came up with a
little man because it's something that
he uh often jokes about so he he calls
other people the little man and said
like okay well he's the little man
what if I listen to him I would have
never done that video I would have never
never built the channel I would have
been in a totally different place a much
smaller place a much more negative place
a much more self-defeating place because
I was trying to you know fit into his
box and so you know I'm grateful that I
had the courage at the time at least to
trust my gut and go with it but it says
constant battle that we face is the
voice inside our head telling us that
we're not good enough it's the people
around us telling us that we're never
gonna make it sometimes out of love and
sometimes out of insecurity and it's why
I think everybody has Michael Jordan
level Talent has helped them like you
could be the greatest it's why I believe
is the number one problem in the world
lack of belief is the number one problem
in the everything else is solvable
believing that you could be the Michael
Jordan of something that you you have
the ability to be the greatest in the
world at something that belief like
really feeling that you could be the
greatest in the world of something
how would your life change how would
your actions change how would it change
what you do today right you're watching
this espresso in the morning how does
your life today change if you actually
believe that you had Michael Jordan
level Talent at something
that's what I'm trying to do
and it starts with you kicking out the
negativity in your head rule number nine
don't quit when do you quit you quit
when you don't love it anymore if you
quit now but you still love it you will
regret that decision the rest of your
life you'll constantly wonder what if I
just gave it one more day one more week
one more month you might have to slow
down and do something else to survive
but you have to keep going if you still
love it so I look at my early days as a
YouTube Creator and you can go back on
my channel and see how awkward I was and
nervous I was and my first video I'm
sitting down in a suit in the tie and uh
and I'm sweating and I'm trying to
memorize my lines and took me all day to
make one video most of my lines were me
reading because I couldn't memorize the
entire script and I was so afraid of not
having to be perfect with my lines and
so I read most of it and had b-roll on
top of it but still it took me a whole
day just to get some of those lines out
on cameras like take after take after
take after take after take and when I
started
on paper looked like a stupid idea I had
no video background I was I'm
introverted it doesn't come across now
but I'm introverted I don't like being a
center of attention I don't go in and
talk to people introduce myself I don't
like the camera being on me I don't like
being in a spotlight it doesn't doesn't
make me feel amazing about myself I
don't crave it I'd much rather be at
home by myself you know with my wife
that's super comfortable for me that's
easy so when I started it was just an
experiment
and even though I wasn't very good at it
I just loved it
I don't know I liked it I'm a visual
learner
and I think people are built to serve
right and I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that I I wish there was
more content for entrepreneurs that was
Visual and that model success Bill Gates
saved my company not not me talking to
him or him investing in my business just
his story how he started I applied and
that started growing my company and I
wish there were more resources telling
the stories of successful famous
entrepreneurs that you could learn from
one just get inspired to say wow look
what they can do but two also to get
specific ideas to help you grow your
business and it didn't exist and so I
thought I'm gonna go make it right
typical entrepreneur nothing exists in
the market so I'm gonna go off and
create it myself
and so it made me do all these things
that I was afraid of that I wasn't good
at that I didn't have natural talent in
and it took me five years to get to my
first 7 000 subscribers right think
about that Journey now I wasn't doing it
every day I wasn't as hardcore committed
I was experimenting and playing with it
a bunch before actually taking it
seriously but I loved it
even now I love it like as much as I'm
afraid to get in front of the camera or
afraid to go and do a speech because I
don't want to disappoint people I still
love it I love it I love serving I love
helping people this is what I this is
what I need to do and so even though I
wasn't seeing a lot of momentum or
traction at the beginning even though
all this stuff on paper looked like it
was against me and I should quit and I
should go do something else
for whatever reason in my heart told me
I can't quit now I have to keep going
and just through sheer perseverance and
and adjusting and developing the skill
set and getting better and becoming more
skilled I slowly got better and now here
we are you know my main channel has over
2 million subscribers and 300 million
views and it's only because I didn't
quit on my dreams when everybody else
would have quit and Rule Number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip stop playing small there will be
periods every single day that you have
the opportunity to build your courage
muscle and what usually happens for most
people is they have this opportunity in
front of them that is scary that they've
never done before that they're afraid of
and they'll justify it with a practical
reason you tell yourself you can't do it
because of all this and it'll make total
sense to you and you just shrink down
you constantly play the smaller game the
weak your game instead of being bold and
believe it in yourself and trying to go
for it and take that action and so how
do you go from being afraid and being
scared to actually Having the courage to
do it here's what I found really helps
it's really helped for me multiple times
and I think it can help you the first
part is the awareness so many people
just play small by default they don't
even realize that they're playing small
it's just so ingrained in you that it
just happens constantly every day you
talk yourself down from things every
single day and it makes perfect logical
sense the reasons why you say you can't
do something are rational they make
sense and so you constantly do it but
when you catch yourself it's usually not
the moments it's like the next day or
the next week you catch yourself to say
you know what
yesterday
I should have done that I should have
said yes I was just too afraid why
didn't I say yes that's self-awareness
that's the start that is the start if
you can realize it don't don't worry
about it being a day later or two days
later a week later if you can realize at
any point that you played small the
other day that's the starting point
because the next time it happens you
want to catch it again it's going to get
a little closer instead of it being the
next day it'll be a couple hours next
time it happens it'll get a little bit
closer next time it happens it'll be as
you're leaving that meeting you realize
almost instantly that I did it again I
did it again I'm playing small I'm
justifying these things when I shouldn't
be I should bet on myself I need to
believe in myself and then the magical
moment happens the magical moment
happens when you have the opportunity
sitting immediately in front of you and
you have the decision to make you catch
it in the moment instead of the next day
or the next week you catch it as it's
happening or somebody asks you the
question to say do you want to do this
and in your head you're thinking about
all the reasons why you can't and you
catch yourself saying this is it this is
what always happens I'm about to play
small again and then develop pain
the courage to say I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna try I'm gonna say yes and what
really helped me is just thinking that I
am tired of living with regret once you
can catch it once you have the
self-awareness to catch that you're
playing small consistently I was tired
of living with the regret of constantly
playing smaller than I should and when
you're in that moment and you have to
make that decision and you're afraid
it's okay to be afraid it's not be
Fearless you're gonna be afraid it's
feeling the fear doing it anyway because
you don't want to live in regret for the
rest of your life looking back on this
moment and saying I played small again
standing up has changed my life not just
standing up for myself and standing up
for what I might believe in and the the
standing up what is it it's not
metaphysical the the the theoretical I
don't know but but actually standing up
like the physical standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
setting up was probably
wow I don't know maybe maybe 20 years
ago 15 years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline could be underneath it and I
get 20 to 40 000 jumps a day on my
trampoline and went through three
trampolines last year because they broke
because most are not designed to be
jumped on that often but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found it when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients I
would be better when I was walking
around
I don't know if it's a nervous energy or
what but when I sat down it was less
energetic less less like let's go do
this thing and when I when I stood up it
was just I had more energy
you test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
fidget with my ring so my ring whenever
I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking
um I like walking around just having
something go and it helps me think and
process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss
again way back in the day and the the
test was not a full-on standard desk
because those barely existed but I took
my bookcase
and I cleared off the book with all the
books in the bookcase and I found the
shelf that was the kind of the best
height to put my laptop on and I just
tried standing there and I think this is
a good life hack not just for standing
up or not but just in general if you
want to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand-up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for to be
delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
the best thing to do is just start find
a small way to just get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase and the first
day I didn't last very long 20 minutes
40 minutes I it didn't last very long
when you're not used to standing up it
it's really hard it's like oh where I
need to sit down and after that first 20
or 40 minutes I got tired and I had to
sit down because my body wasn't used to
it but while I was standing up it's like
I really like this this is cool I have
more energy in just answering emails and
whatever else I was doing at the time I
had more energy so I'm gonna try it
again and that 20 minutes became 30
minutes became 40 became two hours
became four hours became six hours to
the point was like I could just stand up
all day long it became weird when people
came over to my office because there
were no chairs to sit down at so when
we're doing a meeting I'm standing up
and so they were standing up because
there were no chairs and it felt awkward
to have one person standing one person
sitting and then they start getting
tired because after 20 minutes of
standing up we got tired so I had to I
had to bring chairs back to my office to
host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had foot issues I
had uh things that you put in your in
your shoes what they're called not
implants uh customized Souls whatever I
was going to a car like in my 20s I was
going to chiropractor almost every week
because my back was was a mess my knees
were were achy and cracking every time I
was walking like my body seemed to be
falling apart in my 20s I'm now 42 in
May I'm 42 and my body is in better
condition than I was in my 20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier
the move to a trampoline came because I
was I was already standing up for
at least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh
backstage he would always jump before he
goes on stage Tony jumps a couple times
on his rebounder rebounder is just a
mini trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what you have in your
backyard a rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go alright so that's
pretty cool I wonder what he's spraying
in his mouth uh and I like the whole
trampoline thing if I'm already standing
up why not get a trampoline and try and
so again what's what's the easiest way
to go off and do it well I I went to my
local Walmart and I bought a rebounder
and brought it home and
had to adjust the height of my desk and
had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right but
whatever it's fine Lessons Learned right
you figure it out you think do is this
worth doing or not
take the idea that you've got and try
because again the biggest thing that
most people are missing is just momentum
you're just not trying you have this
you've got this idea and we spend our
best energy planning it and ideating and
researching and what's the perfect
trampoline and what's the perfect
stand-up desk and you spend all that
energy researching and then tomorrow you
wake up the next week you come back or
the next month or whatever like nothing
has happened on it still
if all these great intentions but it's
not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them
and so go get the stand-up desk by
creating boxes in your office
you know go get the cheapest trampoline
at Walmart and just jump on it and see
how it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore we
actually moved we just sold our place we
bought a new place and I moved uh into
one of the rooms as a temporary place
where we were showing our place because
my office backdrop doesn't is not very
conducive to selling the house most
people are not used to a stand-up desk a
giant stand-up desk and trampoline and
all that and so I took my office down
because when you're selling a home you
wanted to appeal to everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say sitting is the new smoking right so
try standing up and just give it a shot
and don't stress out if you get tired
after 20 minutes like I did the first
time through it's okay but do you have
more energy while you're working while
you're standing up and if so then just
keep going and just start with the
bookshave for some bookshelves or some
boxes whatever just to get started and
the second lesson is is just do
something just momentum imperfect action
the ideas that you have in your head are
great they're genius you need to do
something you need to stop putting the
gas pedal on the energy that's flowing
through you like greatness is flowing
through you you're actively saying stop
stop stop do something find the smallest
possible way today today like right now
the smallest possible way to take that
awesome idea in your head and build some
momentum towards it
the only thing you're missing towards
your great life is the momentum
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people let you off the hook
people around you will say yeah yeah
it's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
done it you know like that's the worst
feeling in the world that you could have
done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and patting on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry you can't
see we had like you see some here behind
me like look at see that mountain of
snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rocking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to walk on and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like I could look out the window
and say ah so much snow I'm not gonna do
that I'll do it when there's less snow
you know and then the next day there's
less snow there's still snow in the next
it's still snow and then all of a sudden
you just gave up on the Habit right like
you let yourself off the hook to say
I'll do it tomorrow and then and then
you never do it and then the habit's
gone and that's what you're teaching
yourself this is why it leads to
Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
gonna do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why has nobody still upload this
like I gotta get over there I got a
backpack on I'm rocking I'm sweating
like crazy I'm already exhausted now I
gotta go through this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so that's
okay go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snoped your
knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you're not
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
yeah I'm walking through I'm freezing uh
I'm taking one kind of giant step at a
time snow is getting all through my
boots all down my legs I I almost slip
and fall I have a coffee that I that I
picked up uh it's dripping all over the
place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best let's go
let's go Evan you got this man let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating the path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway uh because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step grip by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life you deserve a
great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and
so I love seeing how people do their
daily routines I love I love seeing how
they start today I love seeing what
their workout routines are mindset
routines are because
hopefully you can pick up one little
tweak one little hack one of the things
that you can try out on your own to be
able to make your life a little bit
better I'm sitting here outside genius
Network we've just been having some
amazing meetings I spent the past two
days in a group where you pay 25 000 a
year to be in and the next two days we
have to pay a hundred thousand dollars a
year to be in and I'm grateful to be
able to meet so amazing humans have
built some amazing businesses so this
video leads to a couple of thoughts for
me the first is I think it's great to
have a
healthy balance of ordering chaos most
days you live in order most days you
should have a morning routine most days
you wake up and you do the thing you say
you're going to do most days whether
it's working out or for your business
for your mindset feeding information
into you I go on my believe walks every
morning some of the things I do right
somebody asked me yesterday how do you
say so positive well I go and I believe
walk every morning I go outside get some
sign it's nice here in Arizona let me
show you let me show you I'm it's
snowing right now in in it's I'm filming
this uh the end of April and it's
snowing in in Toronto but I'm here
crazy crazy Sun you know super grateful
we got palm trees in the back I'm gonna
get some of the Sun out of my face but
I go for my believe walk pretty much
every morning and I believe walk what
that is is just helped me set my mind
for the day what do I want to accomplish
today what what am I doing today I
forget you know I forget what my
responsibilities are and why I'm doing
it because no matter how great a day I
had yesterday
today I wake up and feel like I'm
starting over and so having something in
the morning that helps you remind
yourself of the intention that you've
got for today I think is really valuable
it's really helpful at least it is for
me having music on you know putting
music on that makes you bounce makes you
go up and makes you makes you move
because when you move it transforms your
mind as well when your body's moving
your mind starts moving when your body
is slow and lazy and tired and your mind
is slow and lazy and tired as well and
then feeding my brain with with
knowledge with inspiration with it's why
I make all these videos because I want
to learn from the being Gene I want to
learn from Oprah Winfrey I want to learn
from Elon Musk I want to learn from
people who are thinking just way bigger
than me and so I think back to the idea
of order versus chaos most days you
should wake up and and be in order most
days you should wake up and do your
routine most days you should wake up and
do what you said you were going to do
because these are the things that you
know works for you every now and then
though it's great to inject some chaos
because entrepreneurs we love chaos and
it's great to challenge the order and
it's great to see is this thing that I
was doing this is still serving me does
it still work for me is it still
something that I want to be doing and so
that's where going to an event going to
a conference going to meet other people
right so I'm hanging out with all these
successful entrepreneurs here uh in
Arizona and
and it's great and a lot of it is a
reinforcement of what I'm already doing
is working and you hopefully pick up
some nuggets this is what in a 10-day
trip 11 day trip something like that on
my first two days here they gave us uh
free breakfast at the hotel and so my
wife Nina was here with me and we went
for the breakfast the first two days and
I don't usually eat breakfast I don't
usually eat until at least two o'clock
so uh I'll eat between two and six
o'clock every day
sometimes I sometimes I start at two
sometimes I start at six or somewhere in
between I'm usually done by eight and
that's what it is on a daily basis but
since I was away you know you know what
let's have some breakfast and I wasn't
like junking out on every sweet cereal
and syrup all over the place but I
intently kind of went off my routine
still did my belief walk so the music
um and then after two days like you know
what if I keep doing this for the next
10 days 11 days I'm gonna be uh I'm not
gonna feel right you know and so I'm I'm
right now back on my my routine
and the little bit of chaos every now
and then I think is good
it helps you identify is the things that
I'm doing is it working is it helping me
do I want to keep doing it or not what
what is serving me ongoing and so
sometimes you need to get out of your
your environment to to get that shipped
so going to an event going to a
conference meeting other people being
around more ambitious or equally
ambitious people as you can help you
come back with some new ideas even if
you go on vacation you ever go on a
vacation you come back and I want to do
this this this and this you feel you
feel rejuvenated you feel energetic you
feel alive you feel ready to go off and
just make some big change right because
you change your environment and so
that will force some chaos into you that
can hopefully lead to some positive
results so I think most days you should
live in the order you know here's my
routine and I think it works and I'm
sticking to it and then every now and
then you need to inject a little bit of
chaos into it and hopefully in that
chaos it's something positive that
you're injecting into yourself that
makes you pause makes you reflect and
makes you see is this order that I set
up for myself still lead me to the life
that I want one of the things that I
have taken away from the past two days
of hanging with the 25k a year members
is the importance of tracking and
right now what I've done then is started
tracking
what time I eat every day
and what how many push-ups Jumping Jacks
and squats that I'm doing every day and
one of the speakers was talking about in
in general as entrepreneurs what we're
always trying to do is go for new highs
what's our new high break our break a
break a new record right go for new
highs where
a great way to think about it is instead
of always trying to break new highs
because that's
almost impossible to do
just work on your bad days work on
lowering the raising the lows so if
you're thinking about a health goal for
example and you want to you want to hit
a certain weight well you're the average
of what you've done for the past year
right if you if you eat like crap half
the time and eat super healthy half the
time you're gonna get a certain weight
outcome if you eat or fast some days but
then eat super junky other days you'll
get a certain weight outcome so you're
the average of all your highs and lows
and we tend to focus only on the highs
and we don't focus enough on the lows
where if you can just instead of always
focusing on getting better highs just
lowering the impact of the lows then you
can get a better average result which is
what your end result ends up being and
so
you don't know until you track it so if
you're on a health Journey there may be
days you eat super clean awesome and you
can eat cleaner on some days great but
you'll probably get the best results by
those days where you fall off the rails
where you cheat where you make yourself
not so proud where if I'm having
breakfast at the buffet at the hotel on
the bad days you don't let it go too bad
because the concept of bumpers like in a
bowling alley you have bumpers down the
side and so you don't let it get too bad
and so if you cheat or you eat then
you're not having all like pounds of
syrup and everything else that you
minimize the impact or if you're gonna
if you're gonna work out you're gonna
make your calls you're gonna make some
videos that whatever your worst days are
just making them not as bad
and track so by track and you can see
how well you're doing and so I started
tracking what time I ate so yesterday
was the first day so I ate at 6 15. I
didn't get anything all day eight at 6
15 at night and ended up doing I don't
know 50 push-ups 100 squats and 200
jumping jacks something like that and
then today I'll start tracking again and
it gives you a baseline for where you're
at and so that's a new thing that I'm
gonna try and right now my plan is
tracked those metrics what time I ate
how many push-ups Jumping Jacks and
squats that I do every day those four
things that I'm measuring and track that
every day just on a piece of paper and
then on the weekend transfer that into a
Google sheet and uh so I have historic
data now here's the thing it's an idea
right now I'm super excited about the
idea I'm away from my environment of
injected chaos into it and I got
inspired to do this so immediate action
I'm doing it right you don't have to
wait to go home to buy a Fitbit to buy a
fancy tracker to XYZ right this is what
we tend to do you get inspired by
something and then you go off and
you plan and plan and plan and when when
I get home or next week or next month or
on my birthday or New Year I'm going to
do it I said just do it just get started
just just immediate imperfect action is
always the answer
and I'm excited by it right now and it
might be that might make a huge
difference to me it might be a big game
changer it might be all like talk about
you know to to give you advice for the
next 10 years of my life or maybe it
Fizzles out you know or maybe I try it
for three days and I leave here in a
couple days and then that's it and I
don't do it again it's still worth the
experiment and that's what chaos brings
the chaos brings new ideas and the
newness is not productive the newness is
creative but the news is gonna fail a
lot the newness is not going to be
efficient again it won't be productive
and we judge ourselves that every new
idea has to be the perfect idea it's
that's it's the exact opposite
you know like new ideas most of them
will fail it's not that it's a bad idea
it just made it be the right idea for
you at this moment in your life right
now
and so I'm trying it but in general back
to the idea of ordering chaos I think
most days you wake up and have a
schedule
I think most States should wake up and
do the thing at least talking to myself
Evan Carmichael Evan most days you
should wake up and have a schedule we'll
see if you wake up and do the thing that
you said you were going to do and have
your routine and stick to it because
that has consistently gotten new results
and if you keep doing that you'll keep
getting more results
and every now and then you need to
inject a little bit of chaos into it you
need to be around other people who are
doing big things you need to question
the order and question the structure and
ask yourself does this structure right
now still serve me
and is there a better way
and it's in that combination that I
think you ultimately find your happiness
your success your purpose
and then yeah you get the life that you
want when you figure out what you stand
for everything becomes so much easier
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs who
they're doing this and they're doing
that and they're doing this and then
also this thing and it's
feels like it's all over the place right
have you ever felt that you're doing so
many things and it feels like it's all
over the place and you don't know how to
bring it together it doesn't feel like
it fits together nobody understands what
you're doing either
the way to bring it together
is to figure out your most important
core value
if you actually did the exercise and
I've talked about this in in both my
books built to serve your one word
if you actually did the exercise you
think about what do I stand for if you
have to pick something right now your
single most important core value what
would you pick mine is belief what's
yours it has all sorts of exercise we
get into on how to actually do it if
you're struggling with that but just
pick pick something it's not gonna be so
far off whatever comes to mind right now
pick that
now look at everything that you're
creating that you're selling that you're
offering that's in your mind
and they all now kind of make sense
everything that I do
is belief whether it's making videos
like this whether it's
uh making my nft projects with this
going on my Discord whether it's my
other social media content strategies
whether it's speaking whether it's books
whether it's my entrepreneur Heroes
trading cards that we turned
entrepreneurs into into Heroes and made
them made them their own baseball cards
and use that to raise six figures for
Kiva to help entrepreneurs in Africa
build their businesses right whatever
I'm doing it feels like it could be all
over the place but it's not because it's
still belief because at the end of the
day what I want to do is spread belief
Jeff Bezos wants to spread customer
obsession
he wants to he wants to make a better
experience for customers and so he's in
all sorts of different fields
why it feels like it's all over the
place it's not because Amazon is not
just a book business
Amazon is in the customer experience
business
that's his most important core value
what's your most important core value
it'll help make everything make more
sense it'll help make your life make
more sense your business makes more
sense and it'll help your customers
understand better what you're doing I
remember watching a clip of Jay-Z being
interviewed and
they were asking him how do you move
from
making music to being an entrepreneur to
having all these businesses how does
that make sense
and he said it's just an extension of
being creative
see for him it's not just about the
music it's about expressing creativity
and every field can add more creativity
entrepreneurship can be more creative
investing can be more creative product
lines can be more creative he sees
himself not as a musician but as a force
of creativity his most important core
value is creativity so it just makes
sense to him to be able to jump from one
field to another to another to another
where most people are stuck in the craft
right you don't just do one thing you
don't want to do one thing that's why
you're an entrepreneur you don't want to
just do one little narrow thing for the
rest of your life
but it feels like you're all over the
place
and you are
until you can wrap it under your most
important core value and what that does
is gives you permission to explore and
to try and to Taste and to go into new
fields
but also
the ability to do something much bigger
because whatever your most important
core value is that's what you want to
spread to the world
I want to spread more belief to the
world Jay-Z wants to spread more
creativity to the world and he could
have done what most people do
most rappers most musicians stick to
just doing that thing okay well that's
what I love and that's what I know and
so I'm just gonna stick to doing that
how you become Mogul status
right how you start to change the rules
of the game how you start to have a much
wider impact and bigger reach is to
recognize that I don't just do one thing
I don't just have one skill
I've got a message
I've got a core value I want to put out
to the world
and there's multiple ways for me able to
do that
so Jay-Z sees himself through the lens
of creativity and then it makes sense
and it gives himself the permission to
go off and Chase those other ambitions
so for you think about what is that most
important core value and some easy hacks
again both my books go through this in a
lot more detail but think about who your
favorite teacher was growing up think
about who what you loved about your
parents think about your favorite movies
your favorite songs uh think about
anything that made you come alive any
experience why did you love that teacher
for me was my my OAC my grade 12 uh
French teacher why it's not because she
taught me French
your favorite teacher wasn't because
they taught your subject matter because
they made you a better human Madame Farr
at my school she helped me believe in
myself more
when I doubted myself when I wasn't
getting the grades that I wanted to get
she helped turn me from a BNC student to
a straight A Plus student in my last
year
she believed in me and she taught me how
to believe in myself that's why I love
her not because she taught me French
right who was your favorite teacher why
why they made you a better human somehow
what was it about them and when you can
connect the dots and all the things that
make you come alive from your favorite
teacher and favorite books and favorite
music favorite lyrics favorite favorite
TV shows favorite movies favorite
friends right favorite Heroes you can
connect the dots you like them but
instead of it it being a happenstance
like you hope that good things happen to
you you can now design it you can
engineer it
I want to bring more believe into my
life and now that that's on my
Consciousness now that I'm aware of it I
can make that happen as opposed to just
hoping something positive happens to me
when you figure out your one word your
most important core value you can
engineer your life to bring more of that
into you and then the more you have you
can give more you can serve more you can
help more you can uplift up others more
you can motivate and Inspire and give
courage and Hope
to the world more
because you have more to give right
review if you're running on empty you
don't have much to give to anybody
so it starts with that awareness
of what is your single most important
core value
and then bring that to your life
and your business
I believe Bezos is about customer
experience
Jay-Z is about creativity what are you
what are you
what do you value the most
and then with that lens look at your
life
look at your business and see where are
you following through
and crushing it and where are you not
living up to it where are you doing the
wrong things
whatever your life needs a little bit
more of that
because when you can look at your life
through that lens that's your best self
looking back at you
that's the life you want to be living
your highest self looking back to you
and saying hey right here
the reason why you're not happy is
because you're not living your most
important core value
figure that out and you have a road map
you have a guide you have a compass
the rest of your life
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there finding your calling is easy I
think it's crazy that people don't know
how to find their calling I think it's
among the most important questions that
you need to figure out in life like how
are you living